in case you confused it with new york
state as if that's a thing
[Music]
no one but loki sees this and sure maybe
they send this in the cinemasins video
but if you expect me to cross-reference
marvel tv sins with marvel cinemasins
you have grossly overestimated the
amount of work i'm willing to do today
loki low-key logos go slow flow so low
though solo left me loco so i loathe
show
this condensation is never seen or heard
from again in this episode pay off your
setups marvel
this location title did help me realize
the brightness setting on my tv was way
too high but even after correction i
refuse to believe that this font color
on this background passed any sort of
contrast ratio test
this muzzle is just easily removable is
that part of the design it's not like
it's really attached anywhere so why
didn't it fall off you know like the
handcuffs apparently did
i am loki
roll commercial and i am burdened with
glorious purpose fine go ahead get the
episode title in there too now you get a
double roll commercials and an extra sin
for interrupting me you're now moving at
1 16 speed
but feeling all that pain in real time
mondays also this is great on a couple
levels loki getting served in the
comical way it goes on for too long and
you realize it's not just slow motion
but loki's time has actually slowed down
but still and more importantly can there
be a difference in the speed at which
someone feels pain especially blunt
force trauma to the head that's what
really needs to be explained i love the
design of this show truly but this
department with all sorts of time tech
is using a clunky industrial age robot
for intake my cognitive dissonance is
rising and you know how much i hate my
own cognitive dissonance
absolutely not
this is fine as guardian leather
a robot that may or may not be sentient
attempts to use the creepy pinchers
before using the much faster and more
efficient disintegration ray this
particular robot arm please sign to
verify this is everything you've ever
said
this sets up a clever joke but what's
the point of it first even if they tried
to read it all there's no way anyone
could verify what they've said in second
why would it matter the tva to have your
acknowledgement anyway hiddleston
clearly only signs the final sheet here
even though he was asked to sign all
three make him sign all three like you
said is this a scathing satire of
bureaucracy or not take a ticket
what is this a deli
no kids
welcome to the time variance authority
exposition via queue line video
featuring a cute animated mascot
otherwise known as jurassic park's
position except there it made more sense
since it was at an actual amusement park
the tva has stepped in to fix your
mistake and set time back on its
predetermined path i'm gonna have to
remove a sin for cleverly introducing us
to the very morally questionable act of
erasing timelines is there even a word
for what tva is doing chronoside
murderverse whatever it is magamin a
plus for introducing this incredibly
devious premise with this cheeky cartoon
created a nexus event which left
unchecked could branch off into madness
you mean like the nexus mentioned in one
division could lead to the multiverse of
madness marvel you've done it again and
by it i mean throw so many easter eggs
at me that i'm now numb to what reality
even is anymore
owen wilson speaking french sir there's
something you'll want to see the worst
kinds of you better take a look at this
cliches are the ones that are
self-evident you traveled through time
to bring him this file you're handing it
to him i think he's well aware that you
might consider it something he'd want to
see
varian l one one thirty aka loki laufen
is charged with sequence violation
720.89
how do you plead no explanation of the
charges against loki is given at this
trial i vehemently disagree with the
lack of transparency in the judicial
processes employed by the tva good thing
this is only fiction huh as owen wilson
arrives late to this trial i just have
to ask if this place exists outside of
time how does it operate within its own
time like why would owen never be late
to anything could he just come back from
ancient france at a time that would get
him to the trial in a more punctual
manner how are people who travel through
time on a daily basis ever late for
anything we're not here to talk about
the avengers marvel pleading with
audiences to love anything after the
infinity saga somehow makes it into the
episode i thought there was no magic
here there isn't most of what we see
looks a lot like a massive space station
considering all the fantastical stuff
we've seen so far in the mcu are we
supposed to be awed by this why a scene
the idea that your little club decides
the fate of trillions of people across
all of existence at the behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
loki would be glorious at tv sins for
the record this really does feel like a
killing me kind of a room does it i mean
it does kind of have a brutalist vibe
that i'm not a fan of however it's
balanced out by warm tones and some
interesting mid-century modern accent
pieces not to mention the baseboard
lighting if i were murdered in this room
it would be completely my fault for
misreading the situation
can we get some rules on this reset
collar thing does it send the person
back a certain number of seconds to a
predetermined geolocation because over
the course of the show it will somehow
do both the timekeepers have built quite
the circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it wilson and
hiddleston are so good in this scene and
show that i have to take a sin off but
mobius's responses to loki are never
ending loop of being excellent at tv
sins so i'm kind of stuck in a catch-22
here which of course is our way of
saying that the show's gonna catch 22
cents here for making me question my
ability to do my job sorry them's the
rules what is this it's a fancy reverse
expositional device we call it the
previously on the mcu machine and for
the next 30 minutes it's going to do all
the plots heavy lifting in increasingly
more and more convenient
ways did the avengers come together to
literally avenge him by defeating you
little solace to a dead man sure but
actually fury cree corpsed him back to
life with project tahiti sorry tay hit i
so that he could keep working are you
going to mention that oh great
timekeeper we won't stand for agents of
held erasure around these parts do you
enjoy hurting people
making them feel small youtube commenter
recruitment ads
yes this is mischievous but if loki and
thor were gonna go through the trouble
of putting together this whole scheme
just for the thrill of it i feel like
loki especially would have requested
something more interesting than paper
currency i'm not sure what we have here
that would appeal to an asgardian but
two hundred thousand dollars seems like
it wouldn't be worth their time this tva
logo is actually kind of badass with its
old school feel and the hidden hourglass
between the v and the a am i about to
take a sin off for excellent graphic
design the sacred syn line deems it so
apparently but also when i said hidden
between the v and the a i immediately
thought of taints so the sacred sin line
gives and the sacred sin line takes away
i guess
the times position device is apparently
using the same camera movement from the
movie why is sheamus mcgarvey the dp of
the sacred timeline as well what are you
doing
my job
is it your standard yes
right not only is he a great pickpocket
but he quickly figured out how to use
the time device that for some reason was
built without any safety or security
features how do you not know what a fish
is i live my entire life behind it does
this is not an acceptable answer you can
be taught about things that you will
never experience it's basically the
whole reason the kama sutra even exists
also casey is a liar are you behind your
desk right now casey are you case closed
infinity stars
oh come on sure it's a funny joke that
they're worthless here and have many
versions discarded through time but just
because they hold no power here doesn't
mean they wouldn't be protected from
someone getting a hold of them and using
them back in the sacred timeline for
beings charged with protecting time
their evidence processing system is less
organized than my desk drawer in
elementary school no one in this scene
is concerned about the obvious variant
standing unaccompanied by any sort of
security force in the middle of this
office this leads me to believe that
either this sequence of events is
expected or that every one of these
workers is burnout and no longer gives
two facts about the sacred timeline
hunter b-15 is a dick to office supplies
and has absolutely zero concern in
regard to possibly killing her co-worker
the company culture here is atrocious
this episode is all about this version
of loki reckoning with the misdeeds of
his past and the loss of a life that he
will no longer be able to live sure it's
well written and performed beautifully
but i can't help but feel like the
overall goal here is to reshape this
loki into the one that died in infinity
war this loki has to experience a
quickie evolution as if it's his
character arc that is somehow
sacred convenient fast forward to this
exact moment is convenient
you know this would be pretty cool if we
understood how any of this actually
worked but you just keep rocking that
pointless remix duplokey the variant
we're hunting is
you
[Music]
oklahoma doesn't exist no seriously in
1858 the state of oklahoma didn't
officially exist didn't become a state
until 1907. thanks for visiting the tva
don't hesitate to let us know how we're
doing you made me sit through six
minutes of credits to hear this one
lousy question is how i'm doing you time
juggling chrono bastards this decoding
sequence is interesting for precisely
one second after which i have regretful
flashbacks to slot machines in all their
mercury so the sin as always is vegas in
case you confused it with oshkosh bagash
wait maypolling barefoot on this muddy
renfair earth do you know how disgusting
the ground becomes after being saturated
by the tears of larpers i love how this
lady is all you guys are dressed right
as if their futuristic combat gear is
more interesting than having just
watched them walk out of the portal
some of us need this
you know needing renaissance fairs good
thing no one is in this tent right now
in the middle of the fair it's always
nice when people in the past make it
easier for the tva and a variant to not
screw up the timeline none of these
idiots have their weapons activated for
battle i mean at the very least the glow
sticks act as a mild light source on the
other end of the spectrum they can save
your life if you're ambushed which
they're about to be the trap watch your
bats commander c20 then immediately
moves off on her own and exposes her
back towards the darkness like some sort
of rookie [ __ ] also you'd think this
trap wouldn't be much of a surprise
considering there have been so many
attacks on the tva agents oh and also
they'd maybe be tipped off by the dimly
lit tint with unattended doom fire
lapping around as if summoned by satan
we wouldn't dare play the music but the
sin as always is kids i mean bonnie
tyler also i guess the variant is
mischievous just like loki but she can
also clearly use magic and fin for
herself so why turn other people into
mindless fighting drones just cast a
spell and be done with it i guess what
i'm saying is be more like one division
with your spell casting really just in
general all of these mtu shows should be
more like wandavision in all the ways
noki presses the time door button and
then the run program option on the menu
and at no point are coordinates entered
i went along with the unexplained logic
of this contraption because i assumed
that the tva had a special way of
pre-programming destinations but how
would noki know where the time door
leads there's something like 160 letter
changes in this opening sequence and
that is 156 changes too many are you
recording or are you alive and while
we're asking the questions is that a
stuffed weasel someone gets sprinkles on
the line for confirmation because that
poor critter will be able to spot a
fellow tortured soul from a mile away
i'm sure the drabness of the tva office
setting is purposeful but that doesn't
make it any less depressing to look at
it's like someone said what if we could
mix the abram's star trek set with a
cleveland browns uniform then someone
else suggested what about the abrams
star trek set mixed with a cleveland
browns uniform that baker mayfield threw
up all over after a hard night of
partying then the third person said then
stayed in all in tea meeting adjourned i
don't know guys i think i'm pretty sure
i've been brainwashed to get overly
excited to watching marvel characters
don a new outfit this is literally just
loki putting on a suit jacket while
wearing a tie and dress shirt and i'm
screaming at my screen like yeah this is
amazing it is not though stop [ __ ]
with my gauge on what is badass marvel
but which kind of loki remains unknown
no the lesser kind to be clear vanity i
don't want anybody out there to forget
what you are there's like seven people
on this mission and loki doesn't exactly
blend in how would anyone forget who he
is why don't we just travel back to
before the attack when the variant first
arrives oh oh oh i know this one because
then nothing about this show would be
interesting to watch and the drive for
tension and mystery wouldn't be as easy
to reach also mobius is about to give
some gobbledygook answer about nexus
events destabilizing the time flow and
blah blah blah but what it all amounts
to is it's much more convenient to come
to this point so we don't have to
witness the event again so show comes up
with some bs rules for time travel that
doesn't answer loki's question but words
like nexus and time flow were thrown in
to make it sound smart got it good
they're gonna move on also has the tva
never even considered that a variant or
anyone in whatever time they travel to
could snatch one of these grenades i
understand this weaponry provides a
major plot point in this episode and
probably for the series but why wouldn't
they just have a men in black pointy
clicky thing or something less intrusive
and destructive than a
bomb meanwhile this kid is walking
around with his disintegration rod all
lit up like a dumb ass what if loki saw
a snake on the ground jump back and was
zapped into oblivion never ever walk
around with your vamoosh stick fully
erect and activated this is in the
training videos if you leave this tent
you'll end up like them this red
herring's on for some time i approve the
missions speaking of which
let's talk about the one you just
botched did he botch it though they were
sent to assess the situation which they
did mobius figured out loki was lying
and they reset the timeline so there
were no variances the tva agent was
missing before they got there so that's
not really on him and say he did what he
was supposed to do the variant likes to
stall for time and eventually we'll
catch the other one doing the same thing
this might be a hard sell to the boss
considering that just moments before the
mission mobius was adamant that no two
are alike so just because one loki
stalls for time doesn't mean they all do
gonna remember this fan's reaction to
every possible easter egg in this show
somehow makes its way into this episode
i don't care what makes you tick odd
coming from a man who just left an
office attempting to explain how getting
to understand this loki would help him
catch that noki adjusting someone else's
tie without explicit consent
[Music]
i don't need your sympathy characters
delay quippy reply until the elevator
door closes cliche
what's this on the next step just once
can we have an elevator door open up
directly into the middle of a
pre-existing conversation or even more
realistic to silence
happy reading
wouldn't you know it the one file on the
variant that wasn't pulled out to be
reviewed is the one file loki has access
to which leads to a break in the case my
my no one saw this coming what a twist
and i could also
set fire to the palace no just stop
don't set fire to the palace let's
pretend that this video is a new
timeline where we haven't already given
a send back for these hiddleston and
wilson performances i may not be
enjoying most of what i'm watching yet
but these two are gold if
everything and everyone around you is
destined for imminent destruction then
nothing that i say or do
will matter unless of course your action
actually prevented everyone from dying
or allowed a few people to escape the
area before the destruction then it
would 100 matter all kinds of time
branches would happen it's not a
terrible theory but it's also not as
foolproof as loki is making it out to be
in case you confused it with pompe
pennsylvania this entire town has wiped
off the face of its planet how is no one
noticing these two men in suits talking
under this archway come on
let's take walk this is not walking in
the early 1990s for a brief shining
moment there was a beautiful union
of form and function which we call the
jet ski kawasaki started making the jet
ski as early as 1972 and continued to
make the stand-up version that iso
mobius is going on about until 2011 it
was quite a bit more than a brief moment
in time three magic lizards time keepers
how do these three look like lizards who
created you loki this conversation about
the similarities in all religious and
creational beliefs goes on for all the
some time solving the mystery of where
the variant is relies on the discovery
of a pack of chewing gum sure you can
argue all you want about the variant
planting it to attract the tva but what
if mobius hadn't discovered the chewing
gum the only reason he even questioned
it was because the inside of the kid's
mouth was blue what if he never saw the
kid or the kid never even smiled also
the detectives deduce where to go in the
timelines based on when this gum was in
production they literally go to a store
because the store sells it but how would
they know that any of the other
apocalyptic events did not have this gum
what if it was in someone's pocket and
noki stole it have candy on asgard yeah
grapes nuts
i wonder you're so bitter grape nut
shaming this deployment squad did all of
this investigating of what they were
getting themselves into but didn't
consider that cameras might pick them up
when they walked into the store if
anyone's anyone
you're me and she is a she who they
think is a he that can be he's or she's
by just touching a knee just take it
easy every one of us can look at this
man's expression and know that he is
thinking you'd better come take a look
at this and even though it's not spoken
we're still sinning enchantment is a
clever trick is that what you're calling
brightly lit product placement
enchantment damn marketing verbiage is
getting real fancy back in my day we
just called it manipulation what did you
give them the time keepers where they
are how does hunter c20 even know where
the timekeepers are mobius a top agent
hasn't even met the timekeepers i get
the tva is arrogant but that still
doesn't explain why they would let lower
level agents have info they might be
tortured into giving away if one of
these missions goes awry i just want to
point out that in 2050 stores are still
selling wired earbuds i miss randy what
a lot of american idol fans said when
they tuned into season 13 somehow makes
its way into this episode why is loki
going all fisticuffs with this guy he's
got magic use magic
[Music]
okay sure this looks cool but why would
noki go through all the trouble of
wiring the devices across a massive
store when collecting them in one place
behind a locked door would do the exact
same thing it's not like she has a ton
of time on her hands shh
if you listen closely you can hear the
sounds of all the marvel nerds clicking
pause on their remotes and scrambling to
research each of these locations we
honor all of you with this sin nice look
at how long these portals stay open for
everyone to run through i just know the
show will be consistent with how long
they stay open and never close at the
least opportune time just to get this
straight nokie wired a ton of devices to
bomb the sacred timeline installed red
lighting across the store and to be sure
the lights didn't flicker she hooked it
up to a power source so they all
visually punch the point that whatever
is happening is real bad
yeah it's too bad mobius doesn't have an
arm soldier with him that could use a
weapon on loki before he crosses through
the door wait whatever the [ __ ] this
organizational system is
this
this
this
oh
sure hear me complain about too many
letter ships earlier and then add some
more to it 188
shifting letters
you know what brain freeze is don't you
here we go it's when you sip something
so cold so it permeates the roof of your
mouth and freezes the synapses in your
brain so your memories are literally
frozen in place this is not literally or
even figuratively true brain freeze or a
cold stimulus headache has nothing to do
with memory and everything to do with
the pain receptors being exposed to
extreme swings and temperature i
understand that folky here is using
brain freeze as a metaphor for what
she's doing to pour hunter c20 here but
if you're going for a metaphor why not
use deja vu now why did i come into the
kitchen again
okay ask
how many people are guarding the
timekeepers i'm sorry what see if you'd
gone with deja vu this might have worked
this futuristic grocery store has
security cameras that track plot related
people through the parking lot amazing
total bull but amazing
which is more of a sin the sudden
inconvenient timing of folky's time door
or that she's more interested in a top
bun rather than concealing herself with
her hood as she has been doing before
her reveal last episode oh you're right
it's both
you do realize that there are other
available options on the spectrum
between incapacitation through magical
means and
murder by disintegration just a thought
but why not carry the very important
weapon with you if you know your powers
won't work
why is no one picking up the wush away
rod
i'm all for the bad guy killing the good
guys but come on did no one train to use
these light up sticks
she had a sword the whole time
you're in my way only because you walked
away from the elevators which was a
really odd choice given the situation
but now i see
you lack vision well technically this
whole show lacks vision wait was that
even meant to be damon i'm so used to
marvel pummeling my little fan person
brain with easter eggs that i have no
idea if this is supposed to be a
reference to the vision or not 10 cents
for once again making me question the
very fabric of my reality
i'm sorry but this is not the even
standoff it's framed to be sylvie has a
sword while loki has a fist two-fist at
most
goodbye
variant
much more on design this device my phone
leaves me in a state of low battery
panic for at least three anxiety riddle
hours before it finally dies and i'm not
depending on it for any form of
chronometric escapism also shouldn't
this device give you plenty of notice
before it runs out of juice or better
yet prevent you from making an outbound
trip to whenever the if it doesn't have
enough power to get you back home being
stranded some win in a timeline you're
supposed to be protecting seems like a
guaranteed way to make sure your parents
never get together at the enchantment
under the sea dance
well with a name like that you're just
asking for an apocalyptic event of all
of the apocalypses
isn't that the point wasn't the whole
idea of hiding in apocalypses because
there wouldn't be any survivors and
therefore no chance of her creating any
disturbances in the time force or
whatever it is is silvie saying that she
has apocalypses saved in there that do
have survivors that makes none of the
sense i suppose now is a good time to
point out that these two untrusting foes
were trying to kill each other a few
moments ago and suddenly our loki is
totally fine with foki getting this
close and touching his face without any
struggle fine
what exactly is causing loki's daggers
to make this shining sound it's not like
he's unsheathing them doesn't he just
make them disappear and then reappear i
suppose he could be using a minor
illusion spell but that seems a bit
cantroopy for loki i don't know a truce
see a warp i can get on board with but
not a shing
the plan you interrupted was years in
the making
years was it i mean how has sylvia been
able to measure that and if that tornado
in oklahoma was her base of operations
how is she able to spend years there
without i don't know bumping into
herself there's power somewhere on this
moon
we just need enough of it to travel
through interdimensional time and space
where the hell are you going to find
1.21 gigawatts at this hour just because
i have to work with you doesn't mean i
want to hear your voice tv sends writers
when i ask them for feedback on my
narration so let's talk about the
villains play your years in the making
plan was to tear the place down create
the ultimate power vacuum and then just
walk away uh thanks loki you'd be great
at tv since but i swear to odin if you
interrupt me one more time i'm just
checking the coupling making sure it can
connect the pain apple deliberately puts
its users through every damn day there's
a reason their logo is an apple with a
bite out of it here's a confusing part
of the story where loki and foki go into
a tiny house to find a massive power
source brute force is no substitute for
diplomacy and guile
it's been a long time this is what you
call diplomacy i guess the asgardian
definition strays far more into the
manipulative [ __ ] variation hello
dear
patrice i know how the disguise spell
works and sure he may look like patrice
on the outside but there's no way to
nail the voice unless you have the actor
feed and have heard it before this must
be the calmest apocalypse to have ever
apocalypsed is it too much to ask for a
bit of looting or at least an unruly mob
also i'm calling shenanigans that
anything resembling an orderly line
would be maintained here this is the end
of the world people don't wait in line
like this for disneyland let alone their
only possible salvation from the coming
apocalypse also also no one seems to
give a damn that loki and sylvia are
just strolling past cutting to the front
of the line okay there's a couple of
withering stairs but damn it i want my
unruly mob we're doing this one
my way
no one behind them sees this what is in
the water here this must be the most
placid group of people in the multiverse
did the whole of canada just move to
this moon how do i look like someone
with a dead plan loki would be sylvia tv
sins has the train left all those people
behind forgive me if this sounds naive
but surely in a global emergency like
this the goal is to evacuate as many
people as possible there's so much room
left in this card alone why is no one
bothered by the end of the world are you
sure she was your mother uh no she's not
actually i was adopted is that a bit of
a spoiler for you sorry about that no i
knew i was adopted what
they told you so is silly from an
alternate timeline entirely where she
chooses to be a woman and barely
remembers her mother or is she from an
alternate dimension where everything is
different i don't care which turns out
to be true but why the secrecy surely i
can't be expected to root for either of
these mass murderers whatever their
origins but she told me that one day i'd
be able to do it too because because i
could do anything parents who tell their
kids this lie
is there a
lucky bow waiting for you at the end of
this crusade movie has time for this or
tv show acting as though it has the run
time of a movie has time for this so on
the subject of
love
managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a
postman whilst running across time a
post man when does he just install posts
for a living oh she means a mailman huh
he's silly brits what he just delivers
posts all day suppose next you're gonna
tell me works at the post
must have been
would-be princesses
or perhaps another prince
a bit of both
i suspect the same as you the way
lucky's sexuality is revealed here with
zero fanfare just as if it's another
part of his personality is fantastic
still a long way to go but this is a
start you relax your way and i'll relax
mine but why relax at all why not
attempt to drain the power source for
the train at least once before a nap it
is super nice for the apocalypse to
leave the train track and power sources
completely alone as they traverse
towards their destiny i am all for using
headbands as weaponry but really only as
a backup plan to the sword well we
assume the sword works we haven't seen
it slay anyone so far also there's no
way foki's horned tierra wouldn't snag
part of this ridiculously knitted getup
let alone any of the pointy weapons used
in this fight come to think of it their
uniform should be riddled with snags
runs in the one wayward string that you
can't help but pull in fact unravel
should be playing in the background as
this knitted bullshirtery wheezes on she
punches a helmet he punches a helmet and
really what are helmets for anymore
being thrown through a train window
before your intended stop after drinking
too much alcohol or predestination
station defenestration post intoxication
if you will
so does loki's magic just make things
invisible i was expecting some sort of
extra planar pocket dimension
arrangement but the temp pad must still
physically exist or it would have been
destroyed by the fall this also means
loki's daggers are currently albeit
invisibly piercing any number of his
internal organs and god knows where he's
been shoving the invisible tesseract all
along oh the mission the mission what
your glorious purpose uh does anyone
have the commercials for episode one
yeah cool roll them did the
screen make you feel better loki
survives this what about the ark
the ark never leaves because it's
destroyed
whoa nelly let me just grab my tin pad
[Music]
where is everyone
the ark
the evacuation vessel
something like that would have enough
juice to repower the temperature see
back at this lady's house silvie doesn't
seem to have a clue what the ark is so
how does she now suddenly know its
history and that it didn't make it off
the planet and if she did know about it
why didn't she take them there to start
with looks like somebody caught a bout
of the brain freeze you know
i don't think i've ever walked this much
in my life
i'm
strolling on the moon
it's gone a blow up soon
what a
glorious purpose oh my god people where
is your urgency you're about to be hit
with a planet you want to know how
enchantment works
i have to make physical contact and then
grab hold of their
oh how does loki not understand how
enchantment works especially this loki
from 2012 who literally used this exact
power or something extremely similar to
control the minds of hawkeye dr selvig
and half of
just days earlier i have to make
physical contact and then grab hold of
their mind which is incredibly confusing
considering we don't always see folky
touch the person herself but we have
seen the enchanted person grab hold of
her next victim and transfer mental
ownership powers so how does this work
exactly
i've never actually walked for 10
minutes but given the distance i'm
pretty confident if the arc is launching
in that time our pair of keys is
because this is gonna suck
do yourself a favor and believe sylvie
here because the next 10 minutes is just
a whole lot of suck sure it looks like a
lot of things are happening but believe
me when i say that hiding in the spins
power walks running fighting and ducking
nothing is actually happening
okay mister that's a surefire way to get
yourself expelled from the rickon stark
school of running away from things
you've been warned this is an
apocalyptic event report of an airplane
hijacking and bomb threat with zero
fatalities which doesn't seem all that
apocalyptic does it between one minute
of previous lease 35 seconds of marvel
logoing 20 seconds of loki title carding
and 4 minutes and 48 seconds of
end credits we're left with only 33
minutes of content some bastard is
robbing me of over seven minutes of tom
hiddleston and i will not stand for it
imagine if every time you went to a
restaurant they made you sample all the
things you ate the last time you were
there not new versions of those things
the actual things they went to the waste
plant found the remains of your meal and
made you re-eat it after you'd already
processed it and taken what you needed
welcome to previously on segments this
mountain is never seen or heard from
again in this episode i'm beginning to
think marvel uses these establishing
shots for atmosphere only dragon swoops
towards the palace actual footage of the
game of thrones season 8 writer's room
somehow makes it into this episode
that's it just the toys what about the
people she knew the other countless ways
she's impacted this universe's timeline
i know there's talk about erasing entire
realities but why is it leaving the
marble behind when the toys disappear of
the many things this show yadda yaddas
for the sake of our belief staying
suspended i'm tiring the most of this
resetting nonsense i really wish someone
would get this burnout bureaucrat a
drink so he could stop mean mugging
everyone we see ravona and mobius taiwan
on later in the episode he knows what's
going on he's probably just angry he was
never invited who are these people are
they members of the tva and why do they
do nothing to stop this escape maybe
they're just concerned citizens of the
null time zone i'm going to say we have
a florist a tax attorney and the owner
of a small but delightful deli here so
why on their day off are they choosing
to watch these dull ass court
proceedings instead of making me my
pastrami on rye next case
next case
right here the tva court procedures
apparently follow the same rules as
marco polo the tvs technology is
absurdly easy to use or maybe our
technology is absurdly difficult point
is these tin pads don't even require an
access pin or a fingerprint i get a new
tv remote and i have to study it for
hours just to change the input select
but sure program yourself a functional
time door in mere seconds on a device
you've never seen before child look
there's only one explanation for indoor
fog that thick and it's not supernatural
there's a reason the timekeepers keep
asking for more funyuns is all i'm
saying look i know there's protocol she
could have information mobius has been
at this for a while but doesn't seem to
notice how paper-thin their so-called
protocols are other than vendetta's
pruning and paperwork their adherence to
rules is about as strict as a dress code
at burning man what
hell i'm a simple man give me owen
wilson saying wow or how and i'm taking
a sin off all i really want is for him
to star is a farmer turned stock trader
so he can take his cow and sound from
plow to down is that too much to ask
this shot is stunningly beautiful and
all but there are a bunch of meteorites
belting the area sure we're in a
resignation moment here but survival
instinct is strong and there's a tube to
hide in right there if i had paid more
attention in physics i'd be able to
explain to you why two massive celestial
objects this close together should be
wreaking way more havoc than this calm
scene would suggest i'm sure it goes
something like magnetic fields blah blah
gravity blah blah seismic activity blah
blah why is this lake so calm do you
think that what makes a loki a loki
is the fact that we're destined to lose
no according to this show what makes a
loki a loki is the british accent loki's
can be anything as long as they sound
like they're from london despite the
inescapability of the time twister
displacement collar things sylvie loki
and the hunters all go along with this
dramatic hallway struggle walk also why
are they even in the hallway right now
the tim pads can open a glowy door
anywhere why not bring them right into
the time theater a bad memory prison
how quaint
lady siff is a dick to loki
lady siff is a dick to loki's
lady sif is addict to loki because loki
was addicted to lady sifu and now loki's
likely won't stiff because lady sif was
addicted to loki's
also honestly any testicular trauma
after the second loop is on you loki
tuck your low globes away the second sif
walks out i've seen rupaul's drag race i
know there are ways work your low-key
and figure out what caused that spike
j-o-i two variants of the same being
especially you
forming this kind of sick twisted
romantic relationship sick twisted
aren't we supposed to love ourselves
people spend millions of dollars
searching for this kind of therapeutical
breakthrough kip bent mobius but only in
a way that turns and reconnects to
itself so it ends up with only one true
side and a single boundary curve science
jokes how to box your ears damn going
from spirited argument to ear punches is
in no way a healthy progression mobius
really needs to use some of his pto if
you could go anywhere anytime
where would it be
i can go anywhere anytime mobius would
be excellent at tv sins see c20
variant
all these questions what are you getting
at at this point we all suspect ravona
is hiding something but that doesn't
make it any less absurd to be irritated
when someone whose job it is to
investigate things has questions
you've been spending too much time with
loki's yeah
i definitely have been spending too much
time with low keys tvson staff meetings
i'm glad we're back at good old rockstar
because i've got something to say this
is a terrible name for a store sure with
it being low she's hideout it's a fun
play on women having two x chromosomes
and the little logo looks like two
people but i'm just saying the second
you throw another consecutive x in your
store name and only sell regular toys
flashlights or plugs you're gonna have
some very disappointed walk-ins i'm
willing to accept a lot about this
little device okay that's not true i've
pretty much sinned every aspect of it by
this point but if you thought i was
gonna stand by and let you participate
in blatant zoom and enhancing on my
watch well you can just plan a kiss on
my sacred timeline i've heard it once
i've had a thousand times i know right
so why aren't you exploring walk around
look for flaws you're a loki for odin's
sake so you've been misted loki i know
would have solved this room and beyond a
riven by now so i just have to trust the
word two loki's
how about the word of a friend why does
this resonate with mobius he may believe
that loki is not entirely lying but i
feel like the show has spent a lot of
time establishing so much distrust
between these two characters that a
friendship at this stage is very
unlikely i mean i could see this
blossoming into a friendship like after
solving a few cases together mobius
eventually invites him over to have
dinner with the family and mobius
realizes that loki might be crazy but he
means well and then they go and cover a
drug smuggling ring operated by a former
cia paramilitary unit who then kidnaps
moebius's daughter forcing the two of
them to go on a rescue mission which
gets foiled and they're taken to the
baddies hideout and tortured but they
escaped to have to return to mobius's
house because the baddies are going
after his family now but they get there
just in time and the whole thing ends
dramatically when loki fights the main
baddie in the rain now that's a
relationship i would believe
wait are helmets optional now or is this
guy just an anti-helmeter and people are
so tired of his bull they've lost the
will to argue about it anymore that's
what i'm like to do just riding around
on my jet ski prune him holy sh i mean
you know marvel can bring anyone back
and i know marvel can bring anyone back
but loki doesn't know that this moment
is surprising shocking and hiddleston
sells it so well i'm feeling my own
feelings but also jet skis also also
ravona doesn't prune loki here because
we all know you can't prune a loki
without filling out the proper forms and
completing the prerequisite boss battle
tom hiddleston looking good in a shirt
and tie cliche i've lost track of the
number of times i've been killed so go
ahead
do your worst locus only actually died
once in the mcu and he fake died twice
hardly enough times to lose count and
since the one real time and one of the
fake times it wasn't even this
particular loki it'd be a little weird
if he couldn't count to one
[Music]
sure why not why wouldn't someone just
be able to approach unhindered not only
hijack the chrono collars but unlock
them both with one push of a button they
use text making i got a deuce tex
machina i guess
these two guards were apparently trained
to not ever under any circumstance
attack the assailant at the same time
then who
created the tva the disney imagineers
duh
oh please just because the camera didn't
hear or see ravona doesn't mean neither
of the two people in the room would have
heard her get up and approach do you
know how hard it is to sneak up on two
people in an echoey room especially two
loki's marvel didn't think we could
mourn another loki death for more than
two minutes they were probably right but
whether it's their fault or ours it's
still a sin also the possibility of this
loki gator being the leader of this
group tempted me to remove all the sins
from the episode and then promptly
reapply them because i feel toyed with
but instead i'll just give the standard
single sin for taking full four episodes
to go full loki-verse i really love how
weird marvel went with her fantastic
forecasting i wonder who the alligator's
playing choosing to open your show with
a nausea inducing shot do you want me to
paint the screen with my bowl of lucky
charms i just scarfed down marvel
because this is how you get ants i mean
lucky charms vomit lacarms mitt also
there's a great amount of transitory
effort put into this opening sequence
and it makes you feel like something
important is about to happen but it's
just that cleverly repackaged previously
on that points a glaring arrow at the
insane convenience of loki's
introduction in the void in its variant
loki inhabitants what is this place
where are who i am is it the void that's
goliath and we're his lunch come on
richard e grand exposition is the best
exposition it's clear to the point and
concise but every time i see richard e
grant i'm reminded that not enough
people love hudson hawk so
also i wonder how anyone knows the
monster's name is eliath it's not like
it stops for a chat to introduce itself
before annihilating time junk this is it
isn't it this is where you dragged me
after you stole my life yes but can we
back up a smidge and discuss how they
arrived at this place maybe we could
have forgotten that last week's episode
ended with sylvian rinslayer down in the
timekeeper's lair but you just reminded
us of it in the previously awning a
moment ago so sylvie's hair should be
wet and you both should be on that set
and not this set i can help you if you
trust me and despite all reasons sylvia
offers up a tim pad as a symbol of her
trust even though rinslayer never asked
for it and certainly hasn't done
anything to earn it but we gotta get the
show going folks only one more episode
left i'd like to suggest we take a quick
breather so i can ask several thousand
questions so i'm gonna keep moving so we
don't die meaning these new loki's were
on their daily keep moving stroll
through the massive not nyc earlier and
just happened upon our loki tv air dicks
sending people out there into the
whatever verse with no tread on their
shoes why do you wear the horns kid loki
is not wearing horns he's wearing what
could be best described as feathers
classic loki is wearing horns but arloki
isn't speaking to him i would say i'm
confused but that would infer i care at
all about this storyline and or this
show and i do not
i killed full
kids oh look it's yellowjacket helmet
and weathertop what does it all mean
also i'd like to take a moment of
silence for all the marvel fans who've
had to watch this episode 90 times in
order to find and research all the
easter eggs in this one episode it's
like the writers realize that they could
run through the comic book buffet and
scoop a little bit of everything onto
their tray some of it's obvious like
throgg here some things need a more keen
eye i honor you all with this silence in
in the time that none of us will be able
to retrieve after going down all the
easter egg timelines
so
why did you want to return to the tda so
badly anyway better question how is this
underground bowling bunker getting power
supply from anywhere we know where you
hide actual footage of me attempting to
have bathroom alone time somehow makes
its way into the episode well except
with a smartphone and a plunger so
everything she's holding is taken to the
void but
not the weapon that saps her how does
that work holy sh if you drink an
alcoholic beverage you risk pregnancy i
mean obviously the writers drink too
much roxy wine before writing the
government warning and meant to say that
drinking alcohol while pregnant causes
issues or maybe in the pruned roxy
versus drinking alcohol does cause
pregnancy is this an easter egg a clue
damn it mcu tell me your story loki
nobody wants to hear about that he's not
wrong although i may be willing to
listen to a story if it includes the
part about how his costume design
evolved to this after kermit in a dueser
merged design houses polybius perverts
play by producing psychoactive
permutations purposely placed by
pandering policy poo faces who push
psychological programs without
punishment allegedly have any of you met
a woman variant of us sounds terrifying
that's racist i'm gonna kill elias and i
could use all the help i can get
character gives a rousing speech and it
seems like everyone listening is
invested but after it's over they all
burst out in laughter cliche loki was
told early on that there've been
multiple variant loki's and no two are
alike so why are there others that look
like tom hiddleston while all the loki's
have different strengths as far as the
powers are concerned they all appear to
act about the same so what else could no
two alike mean other than appearance
opting to break glass rather than climb
through the hole immediately above your
head having to waste my time looking up
whether or not skinny's pizza was an
easter egg and even if it was it's most
likely a car's reference since lightning
mcqueen is driving the car so this thing
can be for wasting time on pointless
research or having to watch a car's
reference
but i'm giving two because i'm annoyed
oh
look a working car driven by mobius with
enough gas and off-road abilities to
easily drive here right on time to save
sylvie mad moby is fury road
how exactly can one loki name another
loki despite them being essentially the
same being how do you bite the hand off
of a god so illusion kadoki throws
illusion aligoty on numa boki and what i
find most interesting is that aluja
aligoki seems to tackle maboki with
ferocity and substance so is the
alligator an illusion is it real it
seems very real which is exciting
because whatever kermoki does with his
power should literally hold up and not
crumble approaching goliath is a death
sentence
we'll get you to it but that's as far as
we go how is that helpful loki can find
goliath just as easily as these other
two can this show is making a harder
route for a character played by richard
e [ __ ] grant and i watched a little
vampire because of him the little
vampire i guess when you think the ends
justify the means there's not much you
won't do politics what does loki need a
blanket for he was birthed by frost
giants one thing he should never get is
cold tell you what you could conjure me
a new outfit
you have no idea how uncomfortable
something like this is so
don't
wear it
i don't even know what we're doing great
that makes two of us skip conjuring a
communal blanket for someone without
explicit consent and i think if i can
get close enough to it i can enchant it
and it's gonna take me to whoever's
behind all of this this works go
kermoking go do some badass mustard
diaper we are here for it with that
being said if he has this kind of juice
in him why would he wait until now to
use it this would have been super
helpful back at the game of thrones
i think we're stronger than we realized
oh how i love marvel in there blah blah
blah approach to answering important
questions i don't know how
you do
because we're the same much of the
premise of this show has been no two
loki's are alike and now it's betting
that all loki's have the ability to do
anything that their variant persons can
do problem is though that even the
loki's themselves seem to forget their
existing powers for example our loki is
already enchanted and kermoki should
walk through a portal and escape eliath
as a dog returns to its vomit so a fool
repeats his scenes in a previously on
segment or something it's basically in
the bible and that thing's full of sins
no you wouldn't have heard of me
dance off bro it's a friend from work
these opening self blogos accompanied by
the marvel quote all-stars or like that
guy from work that can't quit talking
about is weak and dubai we get it shane
you did some cool stuff now can you
please get back to work those crew neck
tees aren't going to fold themselves
throwing in the moon landing and greta
thunder at the end of 30 full seconds of
marvel miasma to make your opening feel
more important than it actually is i
know disney feels like they own
everything but it seems a little ballsy
to put a post-apocalyptic hogwarts in
your tv show without even getting
permission from warner brothers man i
hope we get to find out all the cool
things about this castle like what kind
of stone it's made of with those awesome
cracks or maybe it was a monster that
did them my money's on the kraken but
i'm sure the show will let us know soon
enough there's no way this episode will
just be scenes of people having
conversations the entire time good thing
that would never happen everybody okay
yeah just need a moment no you take your
moments in episodes three or four at the
latest by the time you're at the final
episode you don't take moments you do
the thing that the show's been building
up to for the past five episodes damn it
loki i'm tired of taking moments i'm
really [ __ ] sick and tired of it phew
sorry about that i'm clearly the one
wearing the horns today i was pruned
before you even existed were you though
i thought pruning was when they
officially zapped you with the rainbow
baton of existential nothingness which
literally just happened before that
weren't you just kidnapped also how do
you know who existed first just because
you got yoinked into the tva first
doesn't mean they didn't pull you from a
time that postdated this loki your words
matter sylvie i have been waiting for
this moment my entire life i just need a
second to get my head straight okay
castle door is addicted people needing a
second
once at a wedding reception i requested
a van halen song but the tj almost put a
chris crosstrack on instead anyhow i
hate jump scares he's impressed who's
impressed hey who remains either playing
the pronoun game when it's not needed or
self nicknaming via the pronoun game i'm
actually so annoyed right now i'm not
gonna pick i'm just gonna give two sins
and sort it out later you can kill
thanos hiddleston's reaction here is
great but would he really have that much
emotion just from seeing a highlight
reel earlier of what thanos did in a
reality he was never even really part of
you want the infinity gauntlet yours i
get that if you're gonna keep an
antagonist around in this kind of
capacity humanizing him is just part of
the process look what star trek
eventually did to the borg that doesn't
mean i have to like it bokey would take
this deal or at least the interesting
version of loki would take this deal the
not deal taking loki is a loki of lies i
mean all loki's are loki's of lies but
this one is a loki of different lies two
loki's in the same place someone hasn't
studied their time cop shooting video in
portrait mode checking for dust without
a white glove on most of dust is human
skin loki and now you're basically
wearing someone else's skin on your skin
you creep oh this is wild what that the
villain eats and apple thing is so
mainstream now that marvel's just
whipping it out front and center instead
of doing it on the sly and hiding their
shame agree come on marvel don't you
realize how naked your cliche is here
only there were a metaphor for the
moment you wake up become aware of your
sin and feel ashamed well either way
come on let's talk
from my office spending any amount of
time in a marvel tv show talking in an
office two sugars thinking the two
sugars can fix the nastiness that is tea
or coffee or whatever drink you've
convinced yourself is actually good even
though it's so bitter it's primarily
responsible for keeping the sweetener
industry in business oh well you know
one man's void is another man's piece of
cake title of my sex tape why is the
coat drive poster in rinslayer's office
wouldn't that be better served out in
the hallway or even on the outside
school walls so more people were aware
of it happening there will be kids
without coats this winter because school
doesn't know how to advertise correctly
calling your school the ohio state
university you're not special but guys
no matter how many articles you insert
before your title everything that's uh
is going to happen
there's only one way this can go does it
involve disney making anus loads of
money i bet it involves disney making
anus loads of money no you can't get to
the end until you've been changed by the
journey this stuff it needs to happen to
get us all in the right mindset to
finish
the quest jonathan majors is not my dm
in this scene free will
free will i give all the sins back right
now if the fresh prince suddenly leapt
over rinslayer from behind and she
trailed her fingers on his skin as he
passed above her and then swam to
freedom beyond's a friendship and you
threw it all away on a couple of loki's
as interesting a character as she's
become i'm kind of starting to wish this
show was called rinse layer instead of
loki but it is not and just who are you
i've been dubbed many
names by many people a ruler a conqueror
we'll get back to your regularly
scheduled sinning here in a bit but damn
i gotta take some sins off the fact that
marvel reveals a major villain sure to
have a huge impact on the mcu in one of
their tv shows to sign the game's
completely changed take some real shonen
ads to put this much faith in your plan
and i've got to give some respect also
jonathan majors is absolutely
pulverizing this role he's so brilliant
compelling and charismatic that i forgot
my job here is to sin things not fan
slobber all over them i'm sorry won't
let it happen again eons ago
before the tva exposition via some sort
of mercury theater is still exposition i
bet you didn't even get permission from
orson welles he discovered that there
were universes
stacked
on top of the zone those look more like
solar systems than universes but
whatever king the expositioner you do
you i love your shoes i love your hair
oh man nice nose thanks man
oh
it happened again didn't it however
not every
version of me
was so so pure of heart and the director
said remember that obvious apple
metaphor from earlier let's pat it home
even more and have him take another bite
right in the middle of talking about the
[ __ ] versions of himself because [ __ ]
subtlety am i right
[Music]
god the way the music is in harmony with
his vocal performance and the general
amazingness of this natalie holt
soundtrack is blowing my mind
nope not again um pretentiously singing
it almond when we all know it's amen
saved it once i isolated our timeline
all i have to do is manage the flow of
time
and prevent any further branches oh is
that all
tva
it works or
you're a liar there are so many more
possibilities than that let's get some
gray in there marvel not every scenario
is black or white marvel or dc laverne
or shirley also side note it's totally
shirley oh villains here one's been a
bit neutered but sure
oh now you use magic i haven't been this
annoyed with mythical creatures relying
on modern weaponry since underworld hot
leather pants glad to see the mtu isn't
faltering on their stabby stabby pew pew
finale resolutions there's something to
be said about being consistently
predictable with the final battles
stop
stop she already did somehow in the
midst of a ferocious kill swing despite
you not saying this till after you
appeared in the direct line of that kill
shot that somehow did not kill you is i
don't wanna hurt you i don't wanna close
my eyes
i don't wanna fall asleep cause i miss
you baby and i don't wanna miss a thing
sorry i i black out and sing aerosmith
when i get bored by what's going on in
front of me there's a reason people have
stopped inviting me to weddings and
funerals it's masturbation but i'm not
you wait you mean not you you or like
not you at all like not a loki or not
this loki if you think making me wait a
year to find out the answer to this
isn't gonna get you a sin you're right
because you're getting five i'm turning
back now hey remember these important
characters that were developed so nicely
through the last five episodes and then
given to doing the finale yeah me either
i should probably start a sidekick's
anonymous support group with taurus from
falcon and sharon and todd davis from
juan division with an emphasis on the
anonymous for all time
always roll king marshalls what are you
talking about who are you what's your
name nice twist you got there be a shame
if someone came along and questioned the
logic of it but why would sylvia have
programmed him to go to an alternate
timeline or universe why would that
timeline or universe be in the exact
same time and with the same people as he
left it and why would those people not
know who he is when the timelines didn't
diverge till after he left how would
there even be a tva in a different
timeline or universe i'm sure you'll
explain it to me in the comments and
marvel will pretend to answer some of
these questions but i'm guessing it
comes down mostly to it's complicated
okay and that ain't enough
breaking the fourth dimensional wall
we are not identical twins oh oh no
no this is fine asgardian leather
leather of course why not the best
a hundred million years ago there were
mosquitoes just like today
and just like today they fit on the
blood of animals
[Music]
welcome to alpha the city of a thousand
planets why does someone with so much
range
just want to rule
it's really not that complicated i got
red in my ledger i'd like to wipe it out
what exactly is it that you want i'll
tell you one thing that really drives me
nuts is people who think that jethro
tull is just a person in the band
give me the tesseract or i'll gut you
like a fish casey what's a fish
guys want corn dogs that's a temporal
anomaly corn dogs didn't come into
existence till the first half of the
20th century
we have a saying
in asgard
only nixon could go to china okay look
you don't trust me you can trust one
thing
i want to kill everyone satan is good
satan is our pal
my name is maximus desmos meridius
commander of the armies of the north
general of the felix legions
loyal servant to the true emperor marcus
aurelius you remind me of them
go down the hall
pull the lever
[Music]
i remember
sorry half an hour ago i was a white
head scotsman
oh i know you did send me back to the
future but i'm back
i'm back from the future not so fast
you're in my way you are my way i'll do
you want better why is gamora i'm the
doctor by the way what's your name rose
nice to meet you rose run for your life
you're not traveled
were you sent here by the devil no good
sir i'm on the level
brute force is no substitute for
diplomacy and guile
diplomatic community
i'm thinking you want him independence
and i'm thinking you weren't burdened
with an overabundance of schooling
the universe wants to break free
so it manifests chaos
i'm an agent of chaos
we get hit all the time by rocks and
meteors some of them the size of cars
some no bigger than your hand
you had rings around them you're amazing
why are you so dominant your father
would have been proud of you jen
timekeepers are watching mobius always
watching i'm watching you wazowski
always watching
fine you want the truth
you can't handle the truth
you can be
whoever
whatever you want to be even someone
good
i like being bad and then going home and
being good
when a shark tank so for those reasons
i'm out you said it's a living thing you
said it's a shark i find him for three
but i'll catch him and kill him for 10.
well life's a beach and then you drive
hang
on here we go you'll never find them
not before she does
and why is that you only want it she
needs it
that doesn't make sense and what have we
always wanted the whole place organized
by style cross reference by size and
reverse indexed by fabric she'll be able
to find anything in three seconds flat
it was some of my best work
pay no attention to that man behind the
curtain and just who are you
i am king
do not be frightened
we mean you no harm you you speak
english i am actually speaking right
by an astonishing coincidence both of
our languages are exactly the same
you came to kill the devil
right
we beat the devil
with our rock
i've lived
a million lifetimes a million dollars
isn't cool you know what's cool a
billion dollars
[Music]
what is this
is this a kissing book